hello everyone and yes i know you guys
are wondering uh still why magnus left
the tournament uh we don't know there is
still no confirmation from any official
source and until uh that happens we will
just continue checking on games when we
finally know of course you guys will
probably know what happened but i will
inform you in the first video that i
make but now let us return to the round
five game of the singfeld cavalier
dominguez perez versus han smoke and
emon quite a brutal game uh you will
enjoy it and it features a very very
difficult pause the video moment uh so
stay tuned for that so uh dominguez
perez uh has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 we have e5 by hans knight
f3 uh knights to c6 and bishop to c4 he
goes for the italian game and knight to
f6 the two knights defense avoiding the
evans gambit with d3 and bishop to c5
now transposing to the joko pianissimo
we have castles and now pawn to d6 c3
and now a6 so a bunch of useful moves
for both white and black a6 a4 bishop
back to a7 and now knight b to d2
preparing the standard rookie one
knights to f1 the knight to e3 or g3 to
f5 and so on so castles the pawn to h3
and pawn to h6 and here we have rook to
e1
and now there are a couple of moves that
are very very popular here for example
rook to e8 the most popular 97 the
second most popular bishop to e6 the
third most popular hans goes for the
second most popular option knight stay
e7 and now we have bishop back to b3 and
this is uh this is somewhat rare but it
has been seen before uh for example uh
maxine barcelo grav defeated wesley so
with knights the g6 here also
vishwanathan defeated nakamura also with
knight to g6 here tonight the g6 is a
known move but the move hans plays pawn
to c5 is a new move so already as of
movie 11 we have a completely new game
and it's a quite an interesting uh
choice preventing white from uh
executing that d4 pawn push that white
always wants to do but also it means as
your pawn is now on
on c5 the bishop is no longer as useful
on this diagonal so at some point the
bishop probably will be remaneuvered to
the b8 so okay knight to f1 bilinear we
have bishop to e6 offering a trade of
bishops and now knight to e3 here if you
trade um of course hans would be very
happy to take with the f pawn then he
gains control of these squares and those
are very important squares for example
you would very much like putting your
knight on f5 at some point this makes it
uh impossible even though you have
double black spawns this is okay
uh so instead we have knights to e3 and
now queen to d7 we have bishop to d2
and rook eight to d8 now we have pawn to
a5 and this is now a very very uh
good position for uh for linear uh he
freed up the a4 square for the bishop
and there are really aren't all that
many squares that hans can use for his
queen so bishop to a4 is coming uh and
now bishop the b8 with bishop to a4 and
now queen to c8 we have pawn to c for
now uh preventing black from also ever
executing d5 and now preparing to put
the knight on d5 so knight to g6 and the
knight to d5 and this is now officially
a monster night you definitely don't
want it there because it controls too
many squares in blacks uh
in black's half of the board uh so of
course hans eliminates it knight
captures on the five c captures and
bishop to d7 now and now uh linear
controls c6 and e6 and it will be
difficult for hans to to maneuver around
around that especially this dark square
bishop as long as this pawn is on d6 and
this pawn is on c5 that bishop is not
coming alive anytime soon so here pawn
ponte b4 a most interesting choice by
nabalinier uh saying that uh if you
capture i'm playing rook to c1 but even
if you don't capture on b4 i'm also
playing rook to c1 and with the queen
and c8 that could be a problem so uh
hans chooses the uh the two of lesser
evil so you could also consider moving
the bishop and then playing queen to b8
but i mean it just looks weird so c
compress on b4 we have rook a to c1 or
rather just rook to c1 that's the only
rook that can come to c1 and now bishop
captures an a4 without this movie it
would be very hands for very hard for
hunts to wiggle out of this one bishop
captures also attacks linear's queen
queen captures and now queen to d7 we
have queen captures on d7 uh accepting
the queen trade rook captures and now uh
rook to c4 preparing to grab the at the
double b pawn but mostly we just want to
play rugby one capture here and then
capture on b7 so how can hans preven
this he plays a bishop to a7 we have
bishop to e3 offering a trade of bishops
and hans trades we have captures
captures also not useful as the knight
no longer can come to f4 and now pawn to
f5 we have e captures on f5 rook
captures on f5 and now again not in a
rush to grab the b4 pawn we have rook e
to b1
uh hans has to go back otherwise the
captures and captures is coming so rook
rook f back to f7 uh knight to d2 and
now comes knight to e7 by hans uh he
wants to
get his knight here then here then here
and then here if he can do this uh
before uh
you know uh
linear manages to organize his pieces
then he should be okay uh a move to the
consider here is maybe e4 uh it's uh the
the engine stock recommendation as it
frees up the e5 square for the for the
black knight uh but you've already uh
you already uh are down one opponent
here yeah the the good thing is you
would have forced white to capture with
the pawn if a knight capture series
played then knight the e7 uh is okay as
now you will have time uh for everything
as the d5 point is hanging as well so
after knight d2 we have knight to e7
attacking the pawn here and now linear
just defends it we have pawn to e4 king
of f8 now comes rook c captures on b4
attacking the b7 pawn and the knights
the c8 the two rooks are now stuck here
guarding the b7 pawn knight to f3 and
now we have knight to a7 so hoping to
get the knight to b5 so you don't have
to keep your rooks here uh guarding the
b the b7 pawn and now d4
not giving hans a moment's rest with e
capture sunday for ninth captures on d4
and now comes pawn to g6 and this is the
moment where uh everyone uh all the
grand masters in the chat as they say
went crazy as they said that of course
um linear is now completely winning uh
but it's a it's a very interesting
position and the g6 move uh
definitely makes it possible uh but why
is this so uh try to figure it out try
to you know uh spot all the intricacies
of the position feel free to pause the
video and try to find uh the best move
uh for linear uh while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is night
the e6 check it's weird i know usually
the cool moves don't start with check
but here it is very important as the
knight there really controls a whole lot
of squares like c7 d8 f8 to g7 uh so
congratulations if you found that but
it's really uh the moves after the 96
check that are that are important of
course linear consider knight to e6 but
basically uh why the g6 pawn matters
king g8 and now you're going to play
rook to c1 and look at how uh black is
without a move you can't move the knight
if you move the knight a rook to c8 is
coming and the knight controls all of
the squares that the black rooks can
retreat to uh uh so you can't move the
knight you can't really move the rooks
where are you moving the rook so once uh
you move okay you can move like rook to
e7 then we go after the pawn and it is
possible like you could also play this
rook here uh let's say h4 we waste a few
moves rook f7 rogue beat to b1 now uh
again uh rook d to e7 and now rook to b6
you are tagged upon again black repeats
and now rook to c3 now you will play
rook to f3 that's the idea with your
rook on b6 and your knight on e6 and
this is much different than what
actually happens in the game
for example if king h8 rook to g3 you
will after the pawn and once black
defends it you play rook to b1 uh rook d
to e7 again wasting a move rook to f3 we
have king to g8 and now king to f2
knights to b5 finally activating the
knight let's say king e3 rook to e8 and
now comes rook b to f1 and now you
really have to trade rook captures on f3
rook captures and now only now uh once
you control the f8 square with your
knight you control the f7 square with
your rook and you control the g7 square
with your
uh
with your knight you will get rook to f6
in and then the g uh g6 uh pawn falls or
the king h7 move defends it but then you
have rook f7 check you pick up the b7
pawn and black's entire position falls
apart so that's basically what you have
what you have to see the knight on e6
allows all of that and the g6 move uh
and made it a bit more possible uh but
here linear plays rook one to b3 he goes
after the rook lift first
prepares rook to g3 rook to f3 now king
g7 and now pawn to h4 so all useful
moves we have knights to b5 now
uh and again knights the e6 check and
you force uh hans into the exact same
position you uh you you do that and then
you then you threaten to go to c8 then
the knight has to go back then you go to
f3 with this rook
and so on so it's still possible but uh
linear did uh missed it the first time
he misses it the second time and if
instead of going knight to e6 he plays
knight captures on b5 and it seems like
it should be okay you are up a pawn uh
but now it's a double pawn a captures on
b5 and now he doesn't even capture on b5
for some reason that is uh that is
pretty weird uh instead he plays rook to
f3 first now he wants to trade off a
pair of rooks but now hans declines this
he just plays rook f3 and now after king
f2 hans finds the incredible rook to c7
uh king to e3 rook to c2 now because
if you capture this pawn this pawn would
fall so he had to bring the king or king
all the way to e3 to guard this pawn but
now this pawn is hanging so rook to f2
offering a trade now rook c1 hans just
declines we have king to d3 rook to d1
with check we have rook to d2 of course
offering a trade but now rook to e1 hans
declines and says i'm just going to keep
attacking this spawn
so you will never be able to capture on
b5 rook to e2 and now rook to d1 check
rook to d2 and not rook to e1 we have
rook to f2 now linear of course would
very much uh
wanted this game to continue but now
rook to d1 with check rook to d2 rook to
e1 and he was in this position on move
47 that linear dominguez perez and han
smok and niemann agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here
basically what could happen is you could
uh finally decide to capture this pawn
but then everything just gets traded off
rook one captures on e4 you're gonna
play rook d to b2 rook captures on h4
real captures on b7 rook captures rook
captures with check and now okay you do
have a past a pawn but it doesn't matter
because after king to f6 you're not in
time to put your rook behind the pass
pawn and your king is too far away to go
here if your king could uh somehow gain
control over uh these uh squares and
prevent the rook from reaching them then
yes but after king c3 of course the rook
immediately will go to a4 and now of
course it's a draw after let's say rook
a7 you defend the pawn king e5 goes
after the pawn and if king b3 rook to a1
no no point in in continuing this if
king b1 just you repeat rook a4 king b3
rook 1 and so on so yeah after rook a1
they agreed to a draw but here
and it's actually uh in a couple of
positions the knight the e6 check was
possible but even though everyone when i
ask you to pause the video absolutely
every one every every last one of you
unless some of you are like you know
considering rook captures on b7 or
something like that everyone consider
knight to e6 check and of course even
linear considered it uh but um i mean if
you don't spot everything then you just
can't play it because the knight is so
well placed here and it has such
potential here once you play this you
can you know you can never unplay it uh
but yeah even after he played rook 1 to
b3 and the king to g7 again 96 check can
win and even after h4 and knight to b5
again knight the e6 check will win
because uh white can always force that
exact same position then uh well
we've said it basically
it's a really fun and weird game but uh
just uh shows you how how complicated
end games are and why end game is the
most important important part of the
chess game that that you should study
uh so yeah that's the game uh hope you
guys enjoyed it if you have any of your
own favorite games from round five or
maybe some of the games that i didn't
cover that were played so far in the
tournament do use hashtag suggestion i i
will go over them i would like to thank
wood uh paul certainly blitz 44 chess
csfi
and the ravishing reptiles youtube for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the scene field cup until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day